but um I have to go to Dallas - I hope
everybody listen everyone anyone that
lives in Dallas or in the Texas area I'm
gonna need help
I've never asked that before but this is
gonna be a tough one
you never draw well and I eat it every
time when I'm there what is the reason -
the reason I don't want your tone bro no
don't do that
why because you're now in the did I say
not saying how dare you you did a good
showcase for your Network thing and now
you're on the cusp of [ __ ] something
great and you look at me and go why do
you say that with your [ __ ] tone
shocked no I'm sorry Irvine shot by
everyone in this room right now breaks
my [ __ ] heart none of you guys even
went to [ __ ] support Gilbert but me
Thank You kalila since senatorial yeah
okay but he also had shows on Tuesdays
and Wednesday and Thursday before you
left you didn't go to any I did I never
knew about it yes you did I told you
every day
I don't listen Jesus I don't listen when
you say stuff but no you know what you
know what it is so big you know how
amazing Gilbert was that night Thank You
Clara
oh he was spectacular that's into the
cry saying you're my Hollywood dad and
yeah let me say this I was like a proud
mommy next to your mommy
nummy seasons this I swear to God I
swear to God if Gilbert asked me
personally I would have gone but he
doesn't you don't you're G you call my
phone number no I do not give me your
phone right now
oh now give your phone your phone right
now you've been doing this for like a
year now a somewhat sad guy takes body
won't do you any good Gilbert it won't
do you any good
you're just you you will text into a
void it's like texting Bobby is like
texting into a half no I don't bro I
asked you what times like hey looks like
hey no no he goes let's see you think
I'm gonna give you my phone number
I'm Bobby Lee who are you no that was it
[ __ ] you too much in my ass you burp oh
you don't
you gave George or don't you touching me
before no George
that it's good that it's Gilbert it's
cuz you don't have my number saved no he
doesn't save you alright can I just say
this right now I'm not I'm gonna throw
this out there no you know what I'm
getting attacked that's fine but I want
to say this I had a conversation several
competitions with Chris D'Elia and I
showed up at the Comedy Store and he
looked at me goes yeah I'm not talking
to you [ __ ] why you don't call people
back you don't text people back you
don't respond to people I don't respond
to anybody and he goes yeah but that's
not right I don't get to me it is fine
if it's if you're saying hey I found out
I have AIDS I'll respond I swear to god
I'm okay with that I'd be like oh I got
a barrage of text messages late last
night yeah that was and I was not only
was i before she gets into that oh god I
got it and go on and sometimes I need
backup and sometimes I need
follow-through and sometimes I need an
army behind me to defend me because
sometimes I'm in dire straits okay and
you know you know you know I go out
there I go out there you know and I do
shows for the company this is the
company yeah and I go to Dallas from the
company right because I'm gonna say this
right now I'm feeling a little resentful
because um you know I've done Opie you
know I've plugged it on every radio
station Tiger belly I've done probably
16 17 18 podcasts Joey Diaz to the other
Mexican to like other ones the other
Mexican as far as you know and and I
plug and I plug and I play I've done
morning of TV hey check out my podcast
Tiger belly I've done it everywhere what
the [ __ ]
have you have you have you done who's
that to everyone in this room I'm
plugging it so if I'm in a dire
situation and my back is it back
to the wall and I need some [ __ ] help
because I'm a human being right can you
please help so that's the precursor to
go ahead I can't wait to hear it this is
that was it
[Music]